Okay.
So we've started talking about,
uh,
the mechanism about carbon eel chemistry.
Uh,
we'll talk today about addition to Carbon Eel,
that mechanism and equilibrium constant about protecting groups.
A little bit of Nmr review at the end if we have time.
And if we really have time,
a little bit about the next topic,
which is oxidation and reduction is involves carbon groups in electron
transfers.
Uh,
so last time we,
uh,
took an overview of basic carbon eel reactivity,
right?
That you can have edition,
you can have addition where the nucleophile attacks,
that's a,
the old burgee done at story.
And then the acid AA comes on to oxygen and you complete it.
Or you can do it the other direction.
You can start with the acid protonating the oxygen first or whatever acid it is,
uh,
and then,
to give a cat oxygen cad I and that stabilized,
uh,
by the,
double bond,
you can draw a resonance structure with plus on carbon and the nucleophile comes
in.
So there are two ways of doing it initially with the nucleophile initially with
an acid,
right?
And we saw that you,
if you have an Alpha hydrogen,
then it's possible to pull it off with base to make an eternal eight and put it
on the back on the oxygen,
right?
So that's,
you can do an Al Lilly rearrangement to an eternal,
it can be base catalyzed via the EDA late.
It also could be acid catalyzed.
You could first put the Proton on the oxygen and then take it off the Alpha
carbon.
Okay.
Uh,
you can also,
because having that functionality ina late an anti and at the Alpha carbon or
the double bond of the Enal,
you can also do alpha substitution.
So we'll see examples of that.
And if you have a leaving group,
the thing is called an acid derivative,
right?
And you can replace it by a nucleophile by in the two step reaction,
first add to the carbon eel,
then remove the nucleophile.
So nuclear Felix substitution of acid derivatives,
uh,
and in the case of carboxylic acids,
right?
You can have addition,
of course,
just as we did before.
Uh,
you can have substitution at carbon where you make a new carbon oxygen bond,
or you can have substitution at oxygen where you make a new,
Oh,
our bond,
right?
And again,
if you have an Alpha carbon,
it's possible to do substitution at the Alpha carbon.
And we'll see examples of that.
Now,
one particular example is what's called Fischer esterification,
which was invented,
you'll not be surprised to hear by Emile Fisher,
right?
And it's substitution at carbon on a,
of a carboxylic acid to convert it into an Ester,
right?
And it's acid catalyzed.
So let's think about how this work.
Where's the acid going to come in and protonate this
Carl?
Yes,
there are two of the Os that's connected by the same alarm.
How do you know,
why should it do that one?
Um,
because water is a good leaving group can send so that,
oh,
just um,
put the age or even at the protons,
I'm asking him where are the best place to protonate is,
um,
that uh,
has,
um,
has the,
come on pairs.
How about the oxygen on top else's and terrace.
So,
um,
let's look at what would happen if you brought,
if you,
if you brought the Proton in on top,
you'd get that cat eye in.
Okay.
Anything good about that one that you can have it be protonate the bottom one.
Anybody see Debbie?
You can get residents stabilization of that one.
Why protonate this one instead of that one?
Well,
notice in the start that this act,
this unshared pear is stabilized by that,
right to buy the low Lumo next door.
So that makes it a little harder to protonate right?
On the other hand,
the one that's up here is it could be a lower energy one if it were in those
rabid he or sp square or a.
So that would suggest that this one might be better,
right?
But it's killed by that and when you protonate but notice this stability you get
there gets even more.
So when you protonate on the top right,
whatever stabilization you had of this unshared payer before you protonated it,
you have more now because you have a lower Lumo to stabilize it.
So you get that special stabilization,
which you can draw by a resonance structure,
that resonance structure.
I,
so you in fact protonate the top,
not the bottom.
Okay?
So once you've done that,
then you can bring in an alcohol and attack the carbon.
It's going to be easy to attack.
Now since a very low Lumo and then lose.
So you get a tetrahedral intermediate,
you started with a trigonal carbon,
three atoms attached to it.
Now there are four.
It's a tetrahedral intermediate.
So notice that as opposed to sn two substitution,
this one first does an addition,
right?
And then loses the leaving group.
They're not both happening at the same time.
So the,
and that's in that sense,
it's analogous to nuclear Philly aromatic substitution.
Here's the nucleophile that comes in,
forms a tetra coordinated carbon.
And then this one is going to leave here.
The amine came in form to a tetra coordinated carbon from the one that had only
three things when the fluorine was down here,
right?
And now this is strictly analogous to that.
What,
what we do next as lose a proton from here and then lose the fluoride right
here.
We're going to lose a proton from here and then lose hydroxide.
So we lose the Proton.
Now of course you don't,
there's an easier way than losing hydroxide directly.
Now you can do what you want to do,
Carl
to that opposite to your favorite oxygen there right now.
Now you've got the leaving group,
but the first protonation was up here and you went through that tetrahedral
intermediate.
It wasn't a case of making this a leaving group and then doing something like an
sn two,
you first did an addition to the carbon eel and then eliminate,
uh,
eliminate the,
the water.
And of course the proton comes off again.
Okay?
So that's the mechanism of,
of um,
of Fischer esterification.
And of course you can run it either direction,
you can run it forwards or backwards.
It's a way of replacing,
oh,
are on the acid,
uh,
carbon,
the carbon yield carbon.
And you can do it with where,
where are his h as well as where our is is some al group.
So you can go either way,
traded them back and forth.
So you,
the way you decide to get Esther rather than getting acid,
which way are you going to go is to have a lot more alcohol than water there.
So you'd drive the equilibrium one way.
If you turn it around and have a lot more water than alcohol,
you'll drive it the other way.
Okay.
So that's fisheries,
their vacation.
Now Victor Meyer we saw last time is the,
uh,
short term supervisor of Moses Gomberg.
And remember what Gomberg did in his lab?
He made Tetra fennel methane,
right.
Which was hard to make because it was so sterically hindered as we found out in
trying to make it with models last time.
But it was fact.
It was Victor Meyer here introduced the idea of steric hindrance in 1894.
He wrote the source of this behavior is stereo chemical,
the space filling of the neighboring groups.
So this was something else that was ahead to the organic model in the 19th
century that we didn't really discuss last time.
We discussed configuration,
the things involving arrangement in space.
Right.
Which was [inaudible] in 1874 we talked about strained rings strain.
That was buyer 1885 and we talked about confirmation,
which socksy tried unsuccessfully to introduce into the discussion in 1891 but
Meyer had the idea of steric hindrance and he said the source of this behavior,
what was this behavior?
What was it?
The basis of his proposing steric hindrance.
It was Fischer esterification in this situation where it doesn't work,
right?
So it doesn't work for two six dimethyl benzoic acid.
When you have a methyl group here in a methyl group here adjacent to that,
then you can't do Fischer esterification.
All right.
Now,
why not?
You can clearly start out here by bringing in a proton and putting it on there.
No problem.
Right?
Where do you get into trouble?
Do you see?
I'll try again.
Um,
when you're going to have to bring in the org because it's going to have to
attack from like that way.
It's going to have to come in from here where this
c is and you're going to try to make that into a tetrahedral carbon with three s
extra substituents on it,
right?
So it's going to earth,
it's going to have the,
the uh,
it's going to have whatever just came in,
right?
So I'm,
Oh,
our group plus this wouldn't protonate it in this one.
Protonated right?
So you've got to get all of these three things here where that's not an age,
right?
That's whatever just came in right adjacent to these two things and it's quite
crowded as you can see here,
that there's,
that there's going to be strain involved in these things running into one
another.
So you can't get to the tetrahedral intermediate of the,
of the Fischer esterification.
And this was actually the basis of the first suggestion that there was such a
thing as steric hindrance.
Okay?
So,
uh,
this tetrahedral intermediate is hard to make if r is really big and crowded,
okay?
But there's a way to,
to make the ester nonetheless.
And it was invented by a guy who sat in some of your seats.
I don't know which seat he sat in when he was a student here cause it was a long
time ago.
So you can't do that.
We can't do Fischer esterification that way.
But Melvin Newman,
who's picture we showed last semester figured out in 1941 how to do this.
And he did it by putting the acid into concentrated sulfuric acid.
All right,
now what happens when you put it into concentrated sulfuric acid,
Carlson,
so pulled into concentrated acid,
it's going to protonate it.
Where will it protonate it?
Um,
topic,
right?
Wrong again.
No,
actually you're right.
Of course you do.
Protonated that.
Okay.
Put it in 100% and sulfuric acid,
you do protonate it on the top,
right for the same reason that we went through before,
but once in awhile you were right originally,
once in awhile it'll protonate on the bottom,
the one you wanted.
And what's good about that?
It's a leaving group,
right?
So in fact,
that can now go away,
right?
Now,
of course,
it could come back again,
right?
But in concentrated sulfuric acid,
water is all protonated,
right?
And as long as it's protonated,
it can't come back.
It doesn't have the High Homo,
right?
So in fact,
you can make this thing,
which is called an ace,
silly of Ion,
right?
And now what he does is take this concentrated sulfuric acid and pour it
carefully into water.
Or pardon me,
into alcohol,
right?
So as he pours it into alcohol,
it's no longer concentrated sulfuric acid,
right?
So the acid,
so you won't be able to make these things anymore.
But alcohol rather than water is the thing that will get the carbon,
right?
So then you'll,
uh,
that inhibits the reversal,
as we just said,
and you pour it into our h and now the OLR traps it and you'll lose a proton and
you've made the Ester.
But notice the difference here,
you made it by dissociation followed by association when it's crowded,
right?
The Normal Fischer esterification is association and then dissociation.
But by doing it in real strong sulfuric acid,
Newman figured out how to do this and the very,
very hindered cases.
Okay.
So now,
uh,
hydration,
of of uh,
carbon eel groups,
which can be done either acid or base.
And that was a note to myself,
which I forgot to take out.
So let's talk about acid catalyzed hydration of formaldehyde.
So I want somebody to help me out on here.
Here at down at the bottom we have formaldehyde and water.
And what I want to do is add to get the hydrate as it's called of the Aldehyde,
right?
The dial that's a hydrate or a gem dial that do o h is on the same carbon.
So how do we do that?
Here we have,
we have,
it's acid catalyzed,
it's hydration.
So we have water and it's formaldehyde.
How are we going to begin here,
Amy?
What?
You said
it's acid catalyzed and what's going to happen?
[inaudible] where are we going to protonate it
[inaudible]
that on and now we have that,
which is a nice stable cad ion,
right?
It's a resonance stabilized.
Okay.
What's going to happen next?
They keep us going.
[inaudible]
oh man,
back the cat ion.
So now we got that
and finally we're getting pretty close to the product.
What do we have to do?
So you just have to lose the proton though.
And you know,
it doesn't just fly off and alcohol will take it or something.
Okay.
Or water.
Okay,
so we've done it.
Okay.
So that's acid catalyzed hydration to formaldehyde.
Now how about base catalyzed hydration of Formaldehyde?
Uh,
need someone to help us here,
Laura.
And how about you?
So what's going to attack one?
[inaudible]
we got base for catalyst.
Notice we got the h plus back again here.
It was catalytic,
right?
Hey minute first came out again.
So o h minus is going to come in at first to come out again.
It's base capitalized and we got water,
we got an Aldehyde.
What are we got?
In fact the VOA
[inaudible] on which APP?
Overseas.
Pardon me?
On the seat,
right?
This is our old favorite attack.
You
pies star.
So that'll come down there and you already got that.
But what we need is a hydrate
the gem dial.
So what's going to happen next?
What do we need in order to get there?
To get from here to here?
What Adam do we need
proton?
Where do we go for water
base?
Right?
So we're not going to get it from h plus,
right?
We're going to get it from water.
So the water will come down,
do an sn,
two type reaction.
That hydrogen substitution,
that hydrogen,
and we got the product and hydroxide,
which comes back and catalyzes another one lives to fight another day.
Okay?
So either acid or base catalyzed,
uh,
schemes will work for that.
Now how about independent of which catalysts you use?
They're going to be an equilibrium constant between water plus the Aldehyde and
the dial,
the gym,
dial the hydrate.
And as luck would have it for asset Aldehyde,
the one which has c,
h three and h on the carbon eel,
the equilibrium constant is one.
And now we're going to see how that equilibrium constant changes as we change
what,
what kind of Aldehyde or ketone we're dealing with.
Okay?
So suppose we have formaldehyde.
I want someone to predict for me whether this equilibrium constant is going to
be greater than one or less than one.
Can anybody see any factors that will be relevant?
Alex,
can you see a dip?
We want differences between them.
Listen,
this or between this and that.
It's going to make one or the other more stable and therefore change the
equilibrium constant.
That's a good point.
This angle gets smaller here,
right?
So this ch three could run into the age,
but also,
uh,
the ch three gets more crowded because we got two o's on here now.
So that's a good point.
But it's the one that I've animated second.
Okay.
Which way is that going to change it?
Is it going to make an equal or greater or less than one?
It'll make,
it'll make this one less energetic than that was right.
Lower in energy.
So that'll tend to shift it to the right.
Okay.
Any other factors?
How about anything on the left?
Anybody see anything there
between this and this?
Notice that here we have an sp squared bond to carbon,
and here we have an sp squared bond to hydrogen,
Carl.
Oh,
with the methyl will be more like chunk,
chunk.
Uh,
generally electrons consider carbon is considered donating,
but that's not the factor,
right?
The strength of bond.
Remember the strength of the carbon carbon bond depends on hybridization.
The strength of the carbon hydrogen bond depends on hybridization,
but the carbon carbon bond is more sensitive to hybridization.
Get stronger when you go sp squared than the carbon hydrogen does.
So this,
this one was a stronger bond than that one other,
uh,
has to with respect to the SP squared hybridization,
right?
So that made this one low and this one was high originally because Astirix as we
said,
now we've got this one is now a higher and this one is lower.
So it should shift it to the right.
And indeed both the bond strength that we just talked about and the steric
hindrance,
right?
Both suggest that it should shift to the right.
And it does.
That's a,
it's 20,000.
The equilibrium constant.
Now let's,
let's try this way.
Let's look at acetone to ch threes now,
what do you think?
How about,
how about on the left?
Is this,
is this going to be a better or worse than before?
Then the ones above
[inaudible]
it's got two of these carbon carbon bonds that are especially strong.
So this is good on the left.
How about on the right,
right.
There's even more steric hindrance,
right?
So that one should go to the left from one and in fact it goes,
it goes the other way,
right?
By a factor of 2000 or a thousand roughly.
Okay.
Now look at,
let's look at this.
Let's put chlorine on the,
on the a methyl group on top right now.
Uh,
does anybody have any ideas about that?
Okay,
so the,
the fact of the chlorine will change this bond.
It will also change that bond,
right?
Because its electron withdrawing.
So where can it withdraw electrons better from,
can withdraw electrons better from an sp squared or from an s p cubed bond?
Where does it withdraw better?
Cassie,
you've got an idea
which is the more likely to donate electrons,
s B cubed or sp squared,
which one is going to hold the electrons tighter?
Yeah,
right.
The one with more s will hold tighter and not be willing to give him up so of
chlorine and wants to get them.
It's going to get them better,
uh,
from here than from here.
So it should shift the equilibrium in that direction.
So the electron donation and it shifts it not nearly by factors of a thousand,
but by a factor of 37 okay.
Compared dope when I didn't,
when I had an h instead of a chlorine.
Now suppose we have three Koreans.
Obviously the same direction should happen,
but how big should it be?
Sebastian?
Do you got an idea?
Yeah.
If one chlorine did 37 a factor of 37 so it changed the,
it changed the free energy difference enough to make a factor of 37 right.
What should they do more?
Do,
what should one board suppose if we just put one more in how,
what,
why,
what factors should we
Theresa,
do you think,
bear in mind that if you make the same energy change,
right,
that trans,
because it's an an exponent for an equilibrium.
The energy,
right?
It's a certain factor,
Because if you add things in exponents,
it's like multiplying things,
right?
So if one changes it by 37 the second one,
if things are simple,
would change it by a factor of 37 and the third would change it by another
factor of 37 so if we go all the way from one to three,
by what factor should we include?
Increase the equilibrium constant.
37 squared.
Is everybody with me on that?
Okay.
Now,
37 squared is a little bigger than a thousand right?
And look at that.
It's 28,000 that's better than we had any reason to expect.
Okay.
But it makes sense.
And finally,
what if we have benzene as the substituent?
So Benzaldehyde,
right?
Is that gonna shift it right or left?
What do you think
Arvin?
Do you have an idea?
Where will the fennel be stabilizing things more on the right or on the left?
Why?
Right?
Because you're going to have
homo Lumo interaction between the carbon eel and the Pi System as the benzene
ring.
So it should shift things to the left.
Conjugation should stabilize the Aldehyde.
And in fact it does.
It's a factor of a hundred,
right?
Instead of one,
it's 0.01 so it shifted it to the left.
So all these make sense in terms of what we understand of what controls,
uh,
molecular energy.
Okay.
Now ask the towel formation,
uh,
happens only with acids.
And I think that this is the one,
oh no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Now,
so let's,
let's look at at acid catalyzed Hemi Ke Tau formation from formaldehyde.
This is closely related to a slide that I just showed you.
Okay?
So what we have is we want to get from the Aldehyde to this,
right?
A hemi key towel,
And what was,
so what we,
it's acid catalyzed roa.
H is going to add to this.
And how's it going to happen?
Well,
let's not mess around here,
right?
Let's just go there.
Okay,
so we protonate just as we did last time when we were adding water,
right?
Alcohol comes in forums,
the bond.
Bingo.
We lose the Proton.
It's catalytic,
right?
And we have the product,
okay?
Nobody's surprised by that.
I'm doing,
I'm belaboring this.
I realize we did the same thing last time.
Essentially we did the reaction going the other direction.
Now I'm going back.
But uh,
but it's really important that you get this.
Okay?
Now base catalyzed,
we can do this just like with water,
right?
We bring that in.
May attack the Pi star yet that it takes a proton this time from alcohol instead
of from water.
And we have the Hemi Quito.
So fine.
Okay.
But suppose what we wanted to do was get the key towel,
not the Hemi he town.
Okay.
Now notice that that Proton can attack either oxygen.
It could either protonate Orr,
in which case what would happen if you then broke a bond?
You see which way where you're going.
If you protonate Oh r and then break the bond between o and c
have alcohol,
leave Amy,
and you're just going,
let's go.
You're going right back where you started,
but you can protonate this one as well as that one.
So if you protonate this one and lose water,
right,
then you can,
instead of reversing,
you can continue,
right?
So you,
you lose water and you get that stable cad ion.
Just like this stable cat I had accepted has an r on it instead of the age,
right?
And then you bring another alcohol in and do your trick and you got the full key
towel.
Fine.
We talked last time we went,
spent a lot of time going from the key towel back to the carbon eel.
Now we're just going the other direction,
reversing all of them.
Now let's try to do the same thing with basic Attallah sis.
Is it gonna work?
What's,
what's the first step going backwards for basic analysis.
If we want to start from here and go backwards,
what's the first thing that happens,
Linda?
The base will pull off the Proton right here though.
The,
the acid could protonate either oxygen,
but here when the base has to pull off a proton,
there's only one to pull off.
It can't pull it off from the R and you can't do an sn two.
The pulling of pulling the are off would be like doing an sn two reaction where
I drop side attacks,
the Ar and this old leaves.
But that's a terrible leaving group.
That's not a good one,
right?
So it can only take.
So,
uh,
the ether ethers are inert to base.
They don't undergo sn two reaction.
So it can only reverse.
It can't go on,
right?
So you can get a key towel by acid Catholicism,
but you can't,
you can only get a Hemi Ke Tau with base catalysis.
Right?
And furthermore,
not only is there no way to get the key towel,
but you can't attack the key towel with base either.
Once you've got the key towel,
it's Ah,
it won't attack with base because you can't attack ethers with the base.
Right?
So you,
it's,
it's the old joke.
You can't get there from here.
Right.
Base will not do it with the,
with key towels either making them or taking them apart again.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
this relates to protecting groups and I'm going to do this on the board.
Uh,
if I were talking about pedagogy,
I would say it's good for me occasionally to draw these things just so you can
see a human draw them rather than have them all animated there.
But in fact,
I didn't have time to do this last night.
So there we go.
Uh,
so let's take this off a bit.
So we're going to look at key towels as protecting groups.
Just a couple of examples.
There are plenty of examples in the book.
Okay.
Now are particularly interesting.
Compound is glucose.
Yeah.
Which is an Aldehyde and an alcohol.
In fact,
it's a,
it has many alcohol groups.
It's got Oah.
Oh,
a chair.
H here.
Now remember the,
uh,
the,
key towel or Hemi Aquis towel is formed by reaction of an alcohol with the
Aldehyde.
But now we don't have to add an alcohol.
We've got alcohols in there already to react with the Aldehyde.
Right.
In fact,
we got plenty of them.
And the question is,
which one right now,
if we were to react this oxygen to make a ring with this carbon,
then how many Adams would be in the ring?
How big a ring would it be?
It would have the oxygen,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
It would be a seven membered ring.
Seven membered rings are not so easy to form because they pucker up and things
on opposite sides run into one another.
Right?
So that's not so good.
Obviously if you use this one to attack the carbon,
it would be a three member during.
That's bad.
That's strange.
This one would be a four membered ring,
but this one would be a five membered ring.
That's not so bad.
This one would be a six membered ring and that's good.
So let's see how we could do that.
If we,
if we made a Hemi Aquis towel,
we could have,
uh,
see,
uh Oh h h a s c o h.
Coh.
I'll just draw it that way.
C O h I'll draw that way.
See and now and down here,
ch,
two o h and now this,
this oxygen has to go to there.
So I could draw it this way.
Yeah,
but nobody thinks,
I'm trying to draw what it actually looks like.
In fact,
it's a six membered ring.
It would look like a cyclohexane,
but just for purposes of showing what's bonded to what it's often drawn that
way.
Okay.
So that would be a Hemi key towel.
And it's six membered ring
six ring.
And that thing is called appearances
when it's a six membered ring.
Right
now if it were this carbon,
then we would have c,
h o h and we'd come down here and we'd have ch two o h and we'd have,
Ooh,
here.
And we'd have c h o here coming out.
Oh,
here.
Okay.
And we'd have o,
h and o,
h and this would be one,
two,
three,
four,
five membered ring.
Okay.
And that's called a fewer no's.
Uh,
okay.
It could go either way.
And they're reversible still because we know that with either acid or base,
catalin says you can go back and forth between Hemi key towels.
And,
and,
and the carbonyl group.
Uh,
okay.
Now how could you find out which rings size it is?
Well,
the way it's actually done nowadays is by Nmr.
Right.
But in the old days when they didn't have an Emr,
they had to do chemical transformations to figure out what was what.
So chemical degradation.
Yeah.
So one thing they could do would be to treat it with acid
and alcohol,
say method hall.
So acid can protonate an ooh and then lose water to leave at cad.
I am right.
But it turns out that only one of the,
that one of the ox of the ohs reacts much more rapidly than the others.
Which one is easy to protonate and,
and,
and lose water.
So as to generate a stable cad.
I,
okay.
If we say we protonated this one,
for example,
we generate a secondary cad.
I am protonate this one secondary cad.
I listen secondary cad,
I and this and primary cad.
I am not so good.
This one.
What would happen if we protonated that won
and lost water?
I'll write it down below here.
So we had uh,
Oh h h this,
oh down here,
et cetera.
Suppose I protonated this one and lost water
right
here is the cat eye and I would,
yeah.
And then I could bring methanol in to put the oxygen on there,
lose the proton from methanol and I would have made what?
Functional group if I now have,
oh,
instead of,
Ooh,
up here I have och three.
Everyone sees how I did that,
don't I?
It's the same thing we've been doing all the time.
You protonate lose water,
put the alcohol on Louis Proton that replaces Ooh,
with LR.
Why did it do it there and not do it at all these other places.
What was specially good about this cat?
I am
that the others didn't have
Chris.
Let me draw,
I'll draw the cat eye in here.
Uh,
are here.
So the cat eye and has an o on it,
an h on it,
a carbon on it.
Plus what's good about and this,
this one goes down then to the bottom.
What's good about that cat ion,
Chris?
Pardon me?
It's secondary.
If you want to consider an oxygen as if it were carbon,
but so were all these other secondary,
right?
If you protonated those in lost water,
what's especially good about this one,
if you have an electrode was dry.
Is that good?
The cad ion,
if you have something that's electron withdrawing,
that means it's already positive.
It doesn't want to get more positive.
So the electron withdrawal by the oxygen is going to be bad for this,
but there's something that makes a good Brandon,
right?
The unshared pair on the oxygen is stabilized by this vacant orbital,
You can draw a resonance structure that puts a double bond here and plus on the
oxygen.
Okay,
so this one is the one that's,
that's reactive to make a key towel,
right?
This thing is a key talents.
Got Two o our groups on it,
right?
And that one,
we could make a key towel too up here,
of course,
and not the other places.
So we can make a key towel right now.
Uh,
it's possible under those circumstances to do reactions with alcohol's right.
Do Chew up the other alcohols but not chew up this one,
right?
Because that alcohol is,
is now in the form of och three,
right,
if you will.
We're talking about reactions next class,
right?
That involve reactions of alcohols,
oxidation,
for example.
Okay,
so this is protecting that particular carbon from being reacted by having a full
Ke Tau there.
Now,
then you can take it,
take it apart again by treating it with acid and water,
get it back and see what compound you have.
Which of the oxygens in that chain got oxidized and which ones were not
oxidized?
Compare with known compounds and you know what the size of the ring was because
uh,
it,
because notice that this not only did this group keep this,
Ooh,
keep from getting oxidized.
This o h
that is this.
Ooh,
didn't get oxidized on this side,
right?
And this o h didn't get oxidized there.
So the protection protects not only the Aldehyde from being oxidized,
it also protects the alcohol.
Professor Ziegler,
who,
who we've mentioned,
do teachers come to 20 often is a synthetic chemist.
And always when he teaches a class in synthesis,
he always points this out that people have tunnel vision.
Often they think of key towels as something that protects the carbon eel,
but it also protects an alcohol at the same time that's tied up as an ether and
won't do the reactions that the alcohol would do.
So you can,
so you not only protect the carbon eel,
you also protect the Roa h and a particular example of that is what's called a
THP protection.
So,
um,
so this compound,
all right
can be reacted with Roy h
and acid ketalysis
right?
So how's it going to start out Derek?
You tell,
tell us
where are you going to protonate this.
You can pro
just so you could broaden it.
This whole
all right.
Either hurting particularly good.
There's actually another place to protonate.
That's very good.
Can anybody see Arbonne?
The carbon carbon double bond where?
Top or bottom?
Nope.
Huh?
Okay.
If we put the h plus here,
right?
Why is that good?
Got The h here.
There are now two H's there.
Of course there was one there already.
What's good about that cat iron that,
yeah,
you could say that's what everybody always says that it's stabilized by the lone
pair on the oxygen.
But actually what it does is stabilize the lone pair on the oxygen,
which makes the molecule more stable.
You're right.
That's what everyone says,
that it's stabilized by the lone pair,
but in truth it stabilizes the lone pair.
Okay,
so we got this,
now we got Roy h.
What's it going to do,
John?
What's the Roa to do now
and then what?
Proton,
right?
So we got this and what functional group is this that we now have?
Does anybody recognize this functional group?
It's familiar.
Li Ke Tau,
right?
To ethers on the same carbon.
Right?
But we didn't make it from a carbon eel.
We made it this way.
Right?
Okay,
so now we could do reactions.
Suppose this our heads,
something else coming off that was going to react,
maybe a double bond and we wanted to react that,
but we didn't run a react the alcohol,
right?
That the ether keeps the alcohol safe.
Right?
We do the reaction down here.
Now we need to get the alcohol back again.
Having done what we wanted to do down here,
how are we going?
How are we going to get it back?
How can we remove this stuff?
We can protonate
protonate the Oh,
lose this,
generate this nice stable cad.
I,
and again,
go back.
We'd just go back and forth,
right with water this time.
Go back with water so we can make with,
so this is a protected group for an alcohol.
Keep it from reacting.
Uh,
uh,
I'll mention one other protecting group for Alpha halls here.
Uh,
because they mentioned it in the textbook that many of you have,
which is called t dms.
Yeah.
It's t butyl dive.
Methyl silo.
So t beautiful die methyl silo.
And you start with the chloride.
Right now the chloride has a bond strength.
This bond of 90 kilocalories per mole.
All
right,
but you could react it with Roy H.
Yeah.
And the unshared pair will react to form a bond with silicon,
right?
So now the silicon has five things attached to it,
But then the chloride can leave.
It's not an sn two reaction.
It's an association followed by dissociation because silicon down in the next
row of the periodic table has vacant orbitals that can make a bond with that,
huh?
All
right.
So now we got t beautiful SEI math,
all math.
Oh are right.
And the,
the strength of the Sio bond is 110 kilocalories per mole.
So this is downhill and energy.
Okay.
Now,
so now you can do what you want to do.
Other things in the Ar group without touch with a,
it's not an alcohol anymore.
It's like a little bit like an ether,
right?
But the neat thing is that there's a special way to take it apart.
You can take it apart by treating it with a touch or a methyl ammonium methyl
for n plus assault.
But the business end is fluoride
because fluoride can attack the silicon the same way the unshared pair out
oxygen did here.
And then you can lose protonate and lose the or.
Right?
So this is,
uh,
the nice thing,
the product from the silicon is now as which you don't really care about is the
s I f and the Sif bond is a fabulous bond.
It's a 135.
Okay.
Cows from,
all
right.
So Plus,
plus,
now you're,
you're a r o h once you've protonated,
right?
So the nice thing about this is there not that many things that react with Fluor
ids easily.
It's a terrible nucleophile generally.
Right?
So,
so now you have something that's very selective that will,
that will only do that and take this protecting group off and not mess up other
things that's in your art group.
Right?
And this was invented in the 1970s by a professor at Harvard who got the Nobel
prize in synthetic chemistry,
Professor Corey.
Uh,
so that's those things and now it means,
and their derivatives and the role of electron pair repulsion and Alec
Stabilization.
So I'm going to just introduce this here and we'll finish it next time.
Okay.
So we have a carbon eel.
I know we've been reacting it with alcohols or water,
right?
But let's consider reacting with an mean.
Yeah.
Which actually is certain
similarity to water.
Of course,
it's got the unshared payer and protons on the nitrogen.
The way alcohol has protons on the oxygen.
So this can react.
Yeah,
of course.
That can lose a proton here and it could put a proton on there.
It's probably not the same proton.
Okay,
and this is called a carbonyl.
I mean,
what's the analog when when you have a high oxygen instead of night instead of
an h in there?
What functional group is it?
If this were just an o instead of an n h,
what would you call this functional group?
Yeah,
I see you all bored.
It's a heavy key towel,
right?
That's what we've just been talking about.
But the carbonyl amine is the amine analog.
Now you could do,
because you have this hydrogen here,
you can do something special,
right?
You can lose this.
Ooh.
Say protonate and lose.
It helped out by this
and we get this
right and water.
Okay.
Pardon me?
It would be originally an h plus one.
We use the unshared pair,
but then we could lose the H.
Plus.
So now we have this functional group,
which is called an eme.
Yeah.
All right.
Which is rather like a ketone,
right?
So we got,
we got rid of the oxygen and a replaced that with an ar and the oxygen became h
two o by the same kind of stuff we've been doing.
Right.
So these,
uh,
ear means,
turn out to be very important,
not only in organic chemistry,
but also in biology.
And we'll continue with that next time.
Or actually,
yeah,
we'll,
we'll continue with that.
But this,
there'll be no more on the exam on Friday than what we've done today.
Okay.
Pardon me.
Oh,
forget,
forget the amines.
Okay.
Just do that.
The key thousand heavy key towels.
It means I'll be on the final.